good morning to uk 11. congratulations
what an olympics yeah we were so excited
for you to be here because i'm wondering
what's it like floating on cl on cloud9
i would imagine you're still
processing it yeah definitely still
processing
um you know i still haven't gotten home
yet i got to home soil
but you know florida's my home so just a
short flight away and then i think maybe
it'll it'll hit me a little bit harder
once i can settle in
i always wondered what it was like we
were watching uh
megan saying i love you so much and the
tears streaming down your face
in that moment what were you thinking we
were all so cheering for you
yeah there's a lot riding on that one
moment i mean
24 years of my life you know boiling
down to one specific moment for
one specific week for a race that lasts
40 something
seconds so there's a lot riding on that
one moment to be able to share that with
megan my mom and dad back home and you
know everyone teamed wrestle
everyone had the dressful shirts um in
the in orlando there with the watch
party so it was really special
being able to see them it didn't matter
that one in person to me just being able
to hear their voice and see them was it
hard not having them with you over in
tokyo
yeah i mean i certainly i would prefer
them to be there but if i'm being quite
honest i don't really talk to anyone
that much at swim meets anyways
yeah you need to be in the zone yeah i
don't i don't even i don't really text i
don't talk
um so it was more so after the meet i
would have liked to have them
immediately but
i just had to wait i certainly became
smitten when you said
i'm not racing for medals i'm racing for
my country
can you talk about what that meant to
you because for a lot of people i think
metals metal
metals but that didn't seem to be your
motivation no i've never i've never been
that way in the sport you know i think
the moment you start comparing yourself
to other people wanting to be one person
in particular
or i mean there's been a lot of
comparison between me and michael which
i
i like michael phelps yeah i understand
it i just think it's
um irrelevant it shouldn't pertain to my
swim career what the potential i feel
like i'm capable of reaching that's
that's what it's about for me is
reaching what i feel like my potential
is
most of us will never know what it's
like to be a gold medalist right we see
you in the pool
swimming you got this chest like
superman and then i read a quote from
you that suddenly makes you really
relatable
to all of us and it was this this is not
easy it's not an easy week at all
i would say the majority of them were
not you can't
sleep right you can't nap you're shaking
all the time i probably lost 10 pounds
i'm gonna weigh myself when i get back
and eat some food but it's a lot of
stress that we put on the body first of
all thank you for being honest
yeah second yeah tell us more about that
yeah it's a lot easier to do these
interviews when you're just honest you
don't have to hide anything yeah yeah
it's it's a week of hell from being
quite honest it's
being on the podium of course is
enjoyable but the majority of what not
not just myself not just swimmers i
think the majority of all athletes
it's not necessarily fun the core of the
whole process
um like i said i mean you go you go your
whole life for one moment
that boils down to a race that lasts a
couple seconds
if you're a little bit off that day i
wasn't i wasn't perfect in any race i
wasn't
perfect you know mindset-wise going into
any event you know every every ready
room is different every year is
completely different
um and there's parts of it that suck but
at no point in that quote did i say
none of it was worth it it was all a
great learning learning experience
every part of it i do enjoy it but say
pressure is fine but it's when you turn
it into stress that it becomes a problem
what do you mean
exactly pressure's fine i can't do
anything about what
other people expect me to do it's
irrelevant you know i don't i don't
really care what people expect me to do
with these games it's a it's all about
it's all about me yeah you know i might
sound a little selfish but it's what i
want to accomplish and reaching my
potential everything everything else
everybody else's opinion
they can kick rocks it doesn't it
shouldn't pertain to me when we think of
olympians we don't necessarily think of
vulnerability but when you hear some own
biles
talk about mental health and really lean
into it did did you kind of feel like it
gave you permission
to also be a little vulnerable every
athlete handles it
it different um and and for the majority
of or for every athlete no one else's
opinion should should matter it's up to
the individual so simone
what she did it was her choice and it
shouldn't pertain to anyone but her
so i think a lot of people shouldn't
open their mouth if you're against her
it shouldn't it shouldn't
like affect you in any way shape or form
what this one particular athlete is
doing
did you talk to her at all while you
were there i didn't see any of the
gymnasts i'm not sure if they were
in the in the village at all i do
remember actually in rio
i had she doesn't remember this because
i was no one knew who i was
but actually i think i i sat next to her
at lunch one of the days some of the
some of the gymnasts ate with some of
the swimmers yeah what did you learn
about yourself during this time
during this process i learned that i
gave myself
credit where credit was due yeah and
it's tough because you have to refocus
you have a next race up in 15 20 minutes
you have to just forget about it pat
yourself on the back and then get over
yourself and move on can you show it
what you got next to you right there oh
no didn't even see these pop-ups yeah
megan help me
yeah thank you megan thank you megan
snuck those in
yeah they did a good job oh beautiful
yeah you guys can tell them oh let me
see this
wow i've never held an olympic gold
medal i i am struck by your
humility and you seem to be very humble
about all that you've accomplished
i i think this is great and wonderful
but i get the impression
this doesn't define who you think of
yourself and who you are
no no the fun part for me was i i got to
i got to be a part of the race i think
anybody we would kill to be in my
situation
an olympic final competing for your
country going for a gold medal i think
anyone would want to be in that
situation i don't need that
for for me to be able to remember what
the fun part was from but do you but do
you equate this to
life changing no no no no i don't know i
don't
want my i don't want my life to change i
like i like it the way it is i like my
life before the games
if i'm being honest the sport was a lot
more fun when no one knew my name well
caleb everybody knows your name i hope
it's not going
i hope really i hope it's not going to
overwhelm you because people are just
cheering you on
and so proud of you and for you and and
what how you represent us
but everybody now knows your name that
ship has sailed my friend